So what we have come to know recently
Quran says it has taught the bee to find
the spacious path of thy lord with great
skill.
Today in science we call it the bee
dance
and previously we thought it was the
male bee which was the worker bee.
Today we have come to know
that it is not the male bee, it is the
female bee which is the worker bee. And
the gender used in the Quran in surah
Nahel chapter number 16 verse number 16
and 69 is first and kuli meaning a
female bee. No wonder Shakespeare in his
play Henry IV
he mentions about people talking among
themselves about the bee that the
soldier B the male soldier B they go and
report to the king. Today we have come
to know it is not the male bees which is
the soldier bee. They are the female
bees which are the worker bees and
soldier bees and they don't report to
the king but they report to the queen.
Imagine even the gender of the worker be
the soldier be is mentioned in the Quran
as a female gender which we have come to
know recently.
The Quran says in surah namal chapter
number 27
verse number 17 and 18 before Solomon
marched his host of
men gins and birds
and when they approached a lowly valley
of ants one of the ants said oh e ants
get into the habitations lest Solomon
and his host will trample you beneath
the feet
to think what kind of a fairy tale book
is the Quran? The ants speaking among
themselves. You know we have fairy tale
books. So what type of a fairy book is
the Quran? The ants talking and speaking
among themselves. After science advance
we have come to know the animal or
insect which has the closest resemblance
to the human being is the ant.
The ants bury the dead the same way as
human beings do. They have a
sophisticated method of labor in which
they have supervisors, managers,
foremen, workers, etc. They have a
sophisticated method of communication.
They very often even meet to chat. They
have marketplaces
where they exchange goods. You know,
souks, we have marketplaces. Even ants
have got market places where they
exchange goods. And if in monsoon during
rainy season if while storing the grain
if the grain gets wet the ants get the
grain in the sunlight to dry as though
they knew that humidity
will cause rotting of the grain.
And if the grain begins to bud they chop
off the bud as though they knew that
bdding will cause rotting of the grain.
Imagine Quran speaks about the lifestyle
of the ants 400 years ago which we have
come to recently. The Quran says in
surah kabud chapter number 29 verse
number 41
as to those who take for protectors
anyone besides Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
they build for themselves houses like
that of a spider for verily the house of
a spider is flimsy. Besides the Quran
saying that any human being who takes
for protectors anyone besides almighty
God Allah they're building for
themselves houses like that of a spider.
Talking about the web and the house of
the spider is flimsy. We know that the
web is a very flimsy house. But besides
this today we have come to know that
many a time the male spider is killed by
the female spider.
The relationship of the husband and wife
is not good in the spiders.
So besides the Quran talking about the
flimsy physical nature of the house of a
person who takes a protector besides
almighty god is also talking about the
relationships in the house.
In the field of physiology,
it was 600 years after the Quran was
revealed that Ibn Afi,
he described the blood circulation. And
1,000 years after the Quran was
revealed, 400 years after Ibn Afi,
William Havi made it famous to the
world. So in our textbook, we know the
blood circulation was first described by
William Havi. Actually, it was nafi 400
years ago. This is all media.
And today we know that the food we eat,
it goes into the stomach then goes in
the intestine. Just in a nutshell, as
far as physiology is concerned about the
blood circulation and the production of
milk, the food which enters the
intestine,
the substance of the food, it enters
into the bloodstream through the vessels
of the intestine
and via the complex media very often
through the liver. via the bloodstream
it reaches almost all the organs of the
body including the mammary glands which
is responsible for the production of
milk. So what we have come to know today
about the blood circulation and the
production of milk is mentioned in a
nutshell in the Quran 1400 years ago in
surah Nahal chapter number 16 verse
number 66 we says that verily in the
cattle is a lesson for you we give you
to drink from what is within the body
coming from a conjunction between the
constituents of the intestine and blood
milk which is pure for you to have
and the same message repeated In surah
mmun
chapter number 23 verse number 21 that
verily in the cattle is a lesson for
you. We give you to drink milk which is
pure that comes from the within the
bodies of the cattle and in it are
various benefits and of the meat you can
eat. So Quran speaks about the blood
circulation and the production of milk
in a nutshell 1400 years ago
in the field of medicine.
Previously we did not know that the
honey was obtained from the belly of the
bee.
The Quran says in surah Nahel chapter
number 16 verse number 69 from the belly
of the bees we give you a drink of
varying colors in which there is healing
for humankind. It was only 300 years
before approximately we came to know
that the honey was obtained from the
belly of the bee and now we have come to
know that honey is rich in vitamin K as
well as fructose. Recently we have come
to know that even the honey has got mild
antiseptic properties. No wonder
the Russian soldiers in World War II
they used the honey to cover up the
wound
which prevented the evaporation of
moisture and the healing in the wound
was done with leaving of very little
scar tissue and due to the density of
honey germs and bacteria were prevented
to grow in the wound. And if a patient
is suffering from the allergy of a
particular plant, if honey is obtained
from that plant and given to that
patient, that patient starts developing
resistance to it. Imagine what science
has come to know today. Recently, Quran
mentions that in the honey there is
healing for humankind.
In the field of embryology,
there were a group of students who
collected all the data that they could
find in the Quran as well as the hadith
dealing with embryology and they
followed the verse of the Quran surah
chapter number 16:43
and surah amyia chapter number 21 verse
number 7 which says
if you don't know if you're in doubt ask
the person who's knowledgeable
So these Arab students they collected
the verses of the Quran and the hadith
dealing with embryology and translated
into English and presented it to Prophet
Keith Mur. That was about 30 years back
in the late '7s
and Professor Keith Mur at that time was
one of the highest authorities in the
field of embryology and he was the head
of the department of anatomy in the
University of Toronto in Canada. when he
went through all the translation verses
of the Quran and the hadith, he said
that most of the verses of the Quran
which speak about embryology are in
perfect confirmity with latest advances
of embryology. But there are a couple of
verses which I cannot say that they are
right.
Neither can I say they are wrong because
I myself don't know about it.
And two such verses were the first two
verses of the Quran to be revealed of
surah of surah alak chapter 96 verse
number one and two which says
read recite proclaim in the name of the
lord who has created who has created the
human beings from something which clings
a leech-like substance so professor
Keith Moore said I don't know whether
human beings the embryo embryology means
It's the study of the development of the
human being, the early stages of human
being in the womb of the mother. For
those who don't know, he said that I do
not know whether initial stages of the
embryo
that's the initial stages of human
being.
It looks like a leech or not. So he went
in his laboratory and under a very
powerful microscope observed the early
stages of the embryo and compared it
with the photograph of a leech and he
was astonished at the striking
resemblance.
And later when 80 questions were asked
to him regarding embro in the Quran and
the Hadith he said that if you have
asked me these question 30 years ago
that means from today more than 60 years
back I would not be able to answer more
than 50% because embryology is a new
branch of medicine which has developed
recently
and whatever additional information he
got he included in the new edition of
his book the developing human the
developing human is one of the books
referred
by most of the students throughout the
world in the first year of MBP, first
year of medical college and even I
when I was in the first year of the
medical college
in Bombay if we had to get just pass
marks we used to refer to the book
written by Indra Bir Singh. If you
wanted to score an embryology we had to
refer to the develop a human by
professor Keith Moore. So, Professor
Keith Moore, he incorporated this new
information he got from the Quran and
the hadith into the third edition of his
book, The Devil of Human, which got the
award for the best medical book written
by a single author. And later on, this
book was translated into several
languages of the world. And prophet
Keith Moore said
that
this information in the Quran cannot
come from human source. The author of
this Quran has to be almighty God. And
he said that he has no objection in
agreeing that prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him was the messenger of this god.
Imagine prophet Keith Mur being a
Christian said that.
Quran says in surah tarak
chapter number 96 verse number 5-7
that does not man know from what he's
created he's created from a drop coming
forth from a space between the backbone
and the ribs
what does the Quran mean by saying the
human beings have been created from a
drop coming from a space between the
backbone and the ribs today after
science has advanced we have come to
know that the genital organs in the
human beings
In the embronic
age when the child is in the womb of the
mother it developed from a space close
to the kidney that is a space between
the spinal column and the 11th and 12th
rib.
In the male
the genital organ the male gonads are
the testes. In the females the female
gonads they are the ovaries. And later
on in the embionic age these nital
organs the gonads they descend. In the
female the ovary descends till the true
pelvis
and in the male via the inguinal canal
it descends to the scrotum.
But even after descending in the adult
life yet these genital organs they
receive the nerve supply from the same
space between the backbone and the 11th
and 12th rib and the blood supply from
the iota which is present in the same
space between the backbone and the 11th
and 12th rib and the venus return and
the lymphatic drainage goes to the same
space the space between the backbone and
the 11th and 12th rib. The Quran
mentions in no less than 11 different
places that the human beings have been
created from.
It's also mentioned in surah hajj
chapter 22 verse number 5 and surah
chapter number 23 verse number 13 that
the human beings have been created from
nutvah which means a minute quantity of
liquid.
What does the Quran mean that we have
created the human beings from a minute
quantity of liquid?
The Quran also says in surah saga
chapter number 32 verse number 8 that we
have created the human being from
acquintisence
and we have created the human beings
from salah.
The Arabic word salah besides meaning
quintessence it also means the best part
of the whole. So besides the Quran
saying we have created the human beings
from minded content of liquid, it also
says we have created the human beings
from the best part of the whole. And
today science tells us that only one
spermatzoa
out of the millions of sperms that are
emitted is sufficient to fertilize the
only one out of several millions. So
this one out of several millions the
Quran refers at minute quantity and
salah the best part of the whole one out
of several millions.
The Quran further says in surah chapter
76 verse number two we have created the
human being from Amish from a minute
quantity of mingle fluids.
Today science says that both the male
fluid and the female fluid both are
responsible for the birth of the baby.
So minute quantity of mingle fluids
and besides the male and the female
fluids even the surrounding fluids takes
part prostatic fluids etc. In the field
of genetics
today we have come to know that it is
the sperm which is responsible for
determining the sex of the child. And
today's science tells us that the 23rd
pair of chromosomes in the human being
it determines the sex of the child. If
it's XX it's a female. If it's XY then
it's a male. So it is the sperm which is
responsible for determining the sex. If
the X of the sperm takes part in the
fertilization, then a female is born. If
the Y takes part, then a male is born.
And this is exactly what the Quran says
in Surah Najam chapter number 53 verse
number 45 and 46 that we have created
the human being from minute quantity of
liquid which is ejaculated.
Minute quantity of liquid. Ejaculated
means it has to be a male fluid. The
similar message is repeated in surahama
chapter number 75 verse number 37 to 39
that we have created the human being
from a minute quantity of sperm.
We have created the human being from
minute quantity of sperm then made it
into an alaka then made into mudga then
give it sex male and female. So the
Quran says that the sperm is responsible
for the sex of the child whether it's
male or female in this country of ours
this great country India for reasons
known best to the Indians
in India mainly most of the people they
prefer having sons rather than daughters
and if a lady gives birth to a daughter
very often Often the mother-in-law, she
will blame the daughter-in-law that why
did you give birth to a daughter?
According to the science and the Quran,
if the mother-in-law has to blame
anyone, she should not blame the
daughter-in-law. She should blame the
son because it is the male fluid which
is responsible for discip male or
female. Actually, it's in the hands of
Allah subhana wa ta'ala. He is the one
who makes it male or female. But if the
mother-in-law has to blame anyone, she
should blame
the son
because he is responsible for the sex of
the child male or female.
The Quran says in surah aur chapter 39
verse number six
that we have made the human beings in
stages one after the other in three ways
of darkness. According to professor
Keith Moore, he said that this
verse of the Quran when it mentions the
three ways of darkness, it refers to the
anterior abdominal wall, the uterine
wall and the amnioionic membrane that
the human being is made into stages in
three layers of darkness.
The Quran describes the various
embryological stages in great detail.
The Quran mentions in surah mun chapter
number 23 verse number 12 to 14 that we
have created the human beings from a
quintessence of clay then made it into a
nut a minute qu of liquid then made the
nut into alaka a leech-like substance
then made the alaka into mudga that's a
chewed-like lump then made the mudka
into isama bones then clothed the bones
with lahim that is flesh
And then we made a different creature.
Glory be to Allah who's the best to
create. These three verses of the Quran
described the various emological stages,
the initial stages of development of a
human being in the mother's womb in
great detail.
First it says that I made it from a
nutvah which we discussed a minute cont
that means a leech like substance which
we discussed earlier. The meaning of the
Arabic word alaka.
It has got three meanings. One is a
leech like substance.
It also means something which clings.
And the third meaning of alaka is kil
clot of blood. Besides it looking like a
leech, the embryo in the initial stages
it also behaves like a leech. It behaves
like a blood sucker. It derives its
nutrition from the mother through the
placenta. It behaves like a blood
sucker. So besides looking like a leech,
it also behaves like a leech. The second
meaning something which clings we know
that the embryo clings to the uterine
wall throughout the nine months that the
fetus in the womb of the mother. It
clings to the uterine wall. The third
meaning of alaka is congeal clot of
blood. And today's science tells us that
in the initial stages the blood does not
circulate and the blood clots
in the vessels and it appears like a
cial clot of blood. So all three
meanings of alakal alhamdulillah today's
science says is in perfect confirmity to
latest advances made in embryology.
It further says we placed it in a karim
makin a place of security and we know
today that the fetus is protected
posteriorly by the spinal column
that the backbone as well as the
posterior muscles and anteriorly it is
protected by the anti-abdominal wall by
the amnocardonic membrane as well as the
amniotic fluid which protects the child.
So the science today testifies that the
child is well protected in the womb of
the mother. It further says we made the
alaka into a mudga. A mudga means a
chewed-like lump. So professor Keith
Moore took a plastic seal and made it
look into a leech like sub initial stage
of embryo and then placed it between his
teeth. He bit it to make it appear like
a mudga a tube like lump. And when he
saw it the teeth marks it resembled the
somites from where the nerves develop.
And the Quran continues, we made the
mudg into isama bones, then clothed the
bones with that is flesh. Then we made
it altogether a different creature. What
does the Quran mean that we made it into
allgether different creature? Till this
stage of mudga is
chewed like llam bones flesh. Till this
stage today science tells us the initial
stages of development of a human being
is similar to the development of a fish,
rabbit and many other animals. Only
after this stage does the human
development differ in looks where we
have a head then we have limbs then the
Quran says we made it into a different
creature. Glory be to Allah who's the
best to create. Imagine the Quran
describes the various embryological
stages in great detail.
And prophet Keith Moore he said that
this description given in the Quran
based on shapes alaka leech like
substance mudga chewed like lum is bones
lam flesh is far superior to the
divisions made in modern embryology
where we say stage one stage two stage
three stage four is difficult to
identify the description given in the
Quran is far more superior and much more
easy
and previously the scientist
They thought it was
in the 16th and 17th century
when scientists like Swamadam they
thought that the sperm contained the
miniature human being. The head of the
sperm contained the miniature human
being and then it grew in the womb of
the mother. Later on when they came to
know that the size of the Ow is bigger
than the sperm D. Rafi he said that the
human being is present in the om and not
the sperm.
Later on in 18th century ma paratus he
propounded the biparental theory that
both the om and the sperm is responsible
for the creation of the human being.
They fertilize they form the zygote
which the Quran has described in great
detail.
Furthermore, the Quran says in surah
Hajj chapter number 22 verse number 5
that we have created the human beings
from a minute quantity of clay made into
alaka made the alaka into mudka partly
formed and partly unformed.
This verse of the Quran
was taken to Dr. Marshall Johnson who is
the head of the department of anatomy in
Daniel institute in Thomas Jefferson
University in USA in Philadelphia.
Now we have come to know in science that
if at this stage we cut the embryo and
we analyze the organs we find some of
the organs are formed some are not
formed. So, professor Marshall Johnson
said if we describe this stage of the
embryo as a complete creation, it will
be wrong because some organs are not
formed. If we label it as an incomplete
creation, that's also wrong because some
of the organs are formed. So, there's no
better description than the description
mentioned in the Quran, partly formed
and partly unformed.
In Arabic, it can also be treated as
differentiated and undifferiated. And
prophet Marshall Johnson said that at
this stage some cells are differentiated
some are undifferiated.
Further it's mentioned in the Quran in
surah sagda chapter number 32 verse
number 9 that we have given the human
beings the faculty of hearing and sight.
It's mentioned in surahan chapter number
76 verse number two. We have given to
the human being the gift of hearing,
sight and feeling. So the Quran first
speaks about hearing then it speaks
about sight. And today's science tells
us the first sense to develop in a human
being is the sense of hearing. By the
22nd day the year starts to formulate
and by the fifth month of pregnancy it
is completed and later on the eye splits
open. That's the seventh month of
pregnancy. So the Quran is perfect in
conformity with science. First come the
sense of hearing, then come the sense of
sight. There was an experiment done
where a baby whose mother was a typist,
a newborn baby was taken and the mother
of that baby was a typist and that baby
born to a typist was placed along with
other nine babies who are born to normal
mothers who are not typist. and the
typewriter was sounded. All the babies
were scared except the baby of the
typist because the baby of the typist
was used to hearing the typewriter in
the womb of the mother. So the baby was
used to it. So he wasn't scared. You
know there are many hades which say that
the pregnant woman should read the
Quran. Today science has confirmed that
when the mother is pregnant, when the
lad is pregnant, what she sees, what she
hears, what she listens has an impact on
the child.
I would just like to mention two more
things before in my talk. The Quran
mentioned in surah ayama chapter number
verse number three and four where the
unbelievers say that after we have died
after human beings have died and have
been buried and the bones have got
disintegrated how will Allah subhanana
wa ta'ala almighty god be able to
reassemble our bones on the day of
judgment so Allah gives a reply that
tell them Allah can not only reconstruct
the bone bones. He can even reconstruct
in perfect order the very tips of your
fingers.
What does the Quran mean by saying
Almighty God on the day of resurrection?
He can not only reconstruct your bones,
he can even reconstruct in perfect order
the very tips of your fingers. It was in
1880 that Sir Francis Gold he discovered
the fingerprinting method and he said
that no two fingerprints even in a
million human beings can be identical.
And today people use the fingerprinting
method especially the police, the FBI,
the CIA, the CI to identify the
criminal, the robber. And this
fingerprinting method which we came to
know in 1880, Almighty God describes in
the Quran 1400 years ago. He can not
only reconstruct your bones, he can
reconstruct in perfect order the very
tips of your fingers.
I would like to end my talk by giving
the last example of profashan.
Professor Tarodashon is head of the
department of anatomy in the University
of Shanghai in Thailand and he spent a
great deal of time
in doing research of pain receptors. We
doctors previously we thought that only
the brain was responsible for the
feeling of pain.
Recently we have come to know that
besides the brain
there are certain receptors in the skin
which are called as pain receptors which
are responsible for the feeling of pain.
Without the pain receptors the human
being cannot feel pain. That's the
reason whenever a patient of burn injury
comes to a doctor he takes a pin and
pricks it in the area of burn. If the
patient feels pain the doctor is happy.
It's the superficial burn. the pain
receptors they are intact. If the
patient does not feel pain then the
doctor is sad. The pain receptors have
been destroyed. It's a deep burn.
The Quran mentions in surah Isa chapter
number four verse number 56. As to those
who reject our signs, we shall cast them
into the hellfire. And as often as their
skins are roasted, we shall give them
fresh skins so that they shall feel the
pain. What does the Quran mean by saying
that as to those who reject our signs,
we shall cast them into the hellfire and
as often as their skins are roasted, we
shall give them fresh skin so that they
shall feel the pain, indicating that
there is something in the skin which is
responsible for the feeling of the pain.
And today the scientists and medical
doctors have discovered that there are
pain receptors in the skin which are
responsible for the feeling of pain.
When this translation of the verse was
given to prophet Tarat Rashan, he said
it is impossible. How could a book
written 1400 years ago mentioned about
pain receptors, he could not believe in
it. Later on after verifying the
translation and speaking with other
scientists he was so impressed with the
Quran that in the eighth medical
conference held in Riyad in the
conference itself he saidahillah
Muhammad Allah there's no god but Allah
and prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
the messenger of Allah alhamdulillah